So the first question about dealing with weight loss, how do you deal with weight loss?
So weight loss, uncontrolled weight loss with cancer is called kickesia.
So uncontrolled weight loss with cancer is called wasting syndrome or kickesia.
That's typically if you're losing two to four pounds a week and you're not had changed
your diet.
Trying to lose weight, you're at a state where you're well below your normal weight,
your desired weight, and you can't seem to put the brakes on that weight loss.
What are there things to do?
Now I did share a whole video and blog post on this so do search for that on our blog
as well, but just briefly some of the things that would be beneficial is marijuana.
So marijuana can be really beneficial using medical marijuana in a case of kickesia.
Why?
Because one of the things that marijuana does using it as an animal or even smoking marijuana
can cause a person to have an increased appetite.
So medical marijuana, the side effect that can increase the person's appetite can give
the person the munchies that has been known to say and getting an increase in appetite
is hard because usually with kickesia, it's not that the person is eating 3,000 calories
a day and is still losing weight.
They have other issues that are going out there, they're nauseous, they're not feeling well,
they're having a plate put in front of them of a meal and they're able to eat a few bites.
They just can't feel like they're eating it can't eat anymore.
Well, using marijuana can decrease nausea, can increase appetite, can decrease pain, can
increase rest, so it can increase the depth of sleep that you're getting.
So that can give a person more energy by using medical marijuana.
So it has some benefits there and then also doing some exercise even if you're confined
to bed, getting some 5 pound weights and doing some arm curls, if you can stand up, doing
some squats, stimulating large muscle groups is very beneficial with kickesia because if
you're stimulating large muscle groups by doing arm curls, if you can curl 10 pounds or 15
pounds or 20 pounds, do so, it's very beneficial.
They're collied on the need for glucose in the muscles to make ATP, to make energy, to
use the muscles, it steals ATP, it steals energy, it steals glucose away from the cancer.
It can be very beneficial to help with muscle waste team syndrome.
IV nutrition can be beneficial.
So if you're at a place where you could get IV vitamin C, you could also get IV nutrition,
IV vitamins, that can be helpful, even IV fluids can be helpful in these cases.
Drinking protein shakes, but again, most people that are in a state of conchexia are like,
yeah, I made a protein shake for my husband, but he only drank a few sips of it and he just
won't drink anymore.
That's where medical marijuana has its benefits because we could increase that appetite.
So do go back and watch the video on the blog for more information that can be helpful.